48 horas para dar solución a los
principales desafíos globales entre los
temas tratados en la primera jornada de
la cumbre del grupo de los 20 su
anfitrión se refirió a la recesión
económica producto del cob y 19
la pandemia dejó atrás a muchos
incluidos trabajadores informales
habitantes de zonas rurales y pequeñas
empresas durante la pandemia tuvieron
dificultades para encontrar nuevos
clientes debido a su poca alfabetización
digital a medida que nos recuperamos de
esta crisis los gobiernos deben ayudar a
que las pequeñas y medianas empresas se
vuelvan más competitivas moore con
perder el presidente ruso conectado en
línea abogó por su producción de vacunas
contra el coronavirus
esto es materia grupo
a pesar de las decisiones del g20 no
todos los países que las necesitan
pueden tener acceso a las vacunas
justicieros del sur esto ocurre en parte
por la competencia deshonesta prespuesto
el proteccionismo y porque algunos
estados especialmente los del g20 no
están preparados para el reconocimiento
mutuo de vacunas y certificados de
vacunación en un prisma job axel y
facciones certificado china tampoco
asistió personalmente a la cita en roma
aunque mostró sus intenciones de
apertura económica
china se adherirá a la política nacional
básica de apertura al mundo exterior
goianiense de aprovechar al máximo sus
ventajas de mercado a gran escala y el
potencial de la demanda interna
por su parte el presidente de francia de
manuel macrón se reunió con su homólogo
de argentina corea del sur y con el
primer ministro indio
al mismo tiempo miles manifestaron en
las calles de roma en contra de la falta
de acción para resolver la crisis
climática recordando que en el acuerdo
de parís de 2015 las potencias acordaron
impulsar esfuerzos que limiten el
calentamiento global 15 grados
centígrados un objetivo sin cumplir
nuevamente convertido en meta